bienvenidos comenzamos una nueva emisión
de reporteros en esta oportunidad
reporteros el documental
algunos norcoreanos han sido tildados de
robar recursos pesqueros de sus vecinos
rusia y japón- y lo hacen con las
conocidas redes de enmalle de deriva un
peligro para los buzos también porque
quienes las usan las dejan en el mar una
vez las utilizan pero más allá de esta
afectación a la naturaleza están las
consecuencias que esto está trayendo
para la población local que hace rusia
en estos casos que dicen los residentes
de luego de los recursos ya que se
enfrentan quienes practican la pesca
furtiva
esta es la historia
i
[Música]
ahora cada año hay miles de ellos
en frágiles barcos de otra época vienen
a saquear los recursos pesqueros de
japón y rusia-
son norcoreanos
no están listos para enfrentarse al mar
abierto
y a veces terminan varados a 500 km de
su país
a su novio con el sonido
he vivido en vladivostok toda mi vida y
nunca había escuchado que tales barcos
estuvieran en algún lugar del mar
pescando pero en los dos últimos años
han aparecido en vladivostok casi en
cada playa hay un barco varado
durante varios meses hemos estado
rastreando las redes de pesca furtiva
del país más secreto del mundo y
tratando de entender por qué esta flota
fantasma está invadiendo el lejano
oriente ruso
[Música]
a su problema el principal problema de
estos barcos norcoreanos son las
llamadas redes de enmalle de deriva que
están prohibidas en rusia y su peligro
radica en que se lo lleva todo
pero la fauna marina todos los tipos de
peces todos los mamíferos y las aves
marinas
sergei turbo list es buceador ahora
observa regularmente estas redes durante
sus inmersiones
la última vez vi una de 200 metros de
largo un 50 o 60 metros de ancho hoy en
día mucha gente buceo y los buzos
también trabajan bajo el agua
si uno queda atrapado en estas redes
wi-fi pues no se puede enredarse en
ellas y morir cogimos un peligro para
los buzos y también un posible desastre
ecológico estas redes prohibidas por la
legislación rusa y en muchos países
pueden tener varios kilómetros de
longitud y los pescadores furtivos
norcoreanos las abandonan tras haberlas
usado suben estas redes atrapan los
peces y las tiran de vuelta al mar es un
método de pesca completamente bárbaro
google
[Música]
qué pasó con los miembros de la
tripulación
como con barcos de madera alquitranada y
hélices de plástico navegan por el mar
para quedar varados tan lejos de casa
en vladivostok un hombre ha estado
vigilando sus movimientos durante años
el profesor viácheslav dubina utiliza
imágenes de satélite para su
investigación sobre los procesos que
afectan los ecosistemas marinos
desde 2013 hemos visto una afluencia
masiva de pescadores norcoreanos en la
zona económica de rusia
esta es la frontera marítima de la
federación rusia esta frontera
delimita la zona económica de corea del
norte y está la de corea del sur
esta es la de japón y esta es la zona
neutral
donde los pescadores de todos los países
pueden trabajar y extra
en pocas palabras los barcos de otros
países pueden atravesar estas notas
económicas pero no se les permite pescar
allí en 2013-2014
los pescadores norcoreanos se quedaban
en la parte sur de nuestra zona
económica pero desde el año pasado
comenzaron a desplazarse hacia el norte
y acercarse a la frontera de 12 millas
naúticas de las aguas territoriales de
rusia
el profesor dubina también quiere
mostrarnos sus puertos de origen en
corea del norte
devoto
aquí son barcos de madera amarrados en
fila destino contra otro escape
hay varios miles de ellos
esos son barcos de metal y esos
pequeños barcos de madera viajan de la
manera más económica posible los grandes
barcos remolcan varios barcos pequeños
los barcos pequeños descargan su pesca
en los grandes y obtienen de ellos todo
lo que necesitan redes combustible
el año pasado el clima fue bueno y al
hacer una económica pudimos observar no
menos de 3.000 puntos de luz aquí
[Música]
impresionantes e incontables flotillas
el estado ruso por su parte no da
ninguna cifra
sin embargo cuando hay advertencias de
tormentas los pescadores furtivos
norcoreanos se refugian en masa en las
bahías rusas del lejano oriente en el
marco de los convenios marítimos sobre
la protección de los buques en peligro
rusia no puede negarles el acceso
si murió
entonces para qué
en la bahía de olga a 450 km de corea
del norte se abrió hoy la temporada de
pesca de salmón del pacífico voy a ser
el primer día que ponemos que estas
redes por ahora no hay resultados pero
esta mañana hubo mucho viento
illia y su amigo álex cell intentan por
segunda vez subir sus redes hace sólo
diez días la flotilla norcoreana estaba
estacionada en esta bahía ya habían
venido aquí los dos últimos años
normalmente llegan por detrás del
horizonte y se estacionan en las
varillas circundantes
para estos pescadores la pesca no parece
ser muy abundante es una hembra
la primera del año aquí todo el mundo
está de acuerdo en que desde que los
norcoreanos se instalaron en estas
bahías el pescado y los mariscos se
volvieron muy escasos
se llevaron todo el fondo del mar
pregúntele a cualquiera hace unos dos
años todavía había cangrejos aquí
también tenemos licencias para pescar
cangrejo camarón o pepino de mar pero en
los últimos años todo se ha vuelto muy
escaso sentimos que hay menos de todo
menos recursos pesqueros
como pueblos indígenas del lejano
oriente estos pescadores tienen derecho
a cuotas que varían cada año de 100 a
200 kilos de salmón por persona esta
temporada la guardia costera se
encuentra en la orilla y se asegura de
que nadie aquí exceda su cuota
están apostados allí controlando todos
los peces aunque tenemos nuestros
cuadernos que atrapamos cinco peces
debemos anotar los pero no tienen que ir
a ver cada pescador que sale el agua
para preguntarle por cuánto pescas te
paras vamos a notarlo
la pesca furtiva norcoreana así que
estos pescadores se enfaden aún más
hoy en esta orilla hay 4 656
guardacostas pero me pregunto quién se
ocupa de ellos allá tenemos la sensación
de que se hacen los de la vista gorda
con los norcoreanos mientras que tratan
de sofocar nos azota
están justificados estos reproches los
guardacostas nos ven grabando y nos
abordan dejamos que nuestra cámara siga
grabando y aprovechamos para hacerles
preguntas qué medios tienen para luchar
contra esto hay muchos norcoreanos y
todos ellos pescan furtivamente tratamos
de ponerlos a todos en un mismo lugar y
patrullamos alrededor de ellos les
pedimos que pesquen y desembarque pero
que pueden hacer concretamente cuando
hay 200 barcos pescando llamamos a un
patrullero de la marina costera uno de
los que patrullan en la frontera los
helicópteros y las fuerzas especiales se
movilizan rápidamente el guardacostas
nos asegura que la situación está bajo
control cuando los barcos norcoreanos
están en la bahía pero dice que es más
difícil en altamar por ejemplo ahora no
los vemos pero puede ser que estén
pescando en alguna parte pueden
imaginarse los medios que se necesitan
para patrullar toda nuestra costa a toda
hora
sin embargo el año pasado las
operaciones marítimas aumentaron fueron
grabadas por el fsb el servicio secreto
ruso del que dependen los guardacostas
a 360 kilómetros de la zona económica
exclusiva de rusia los norcoreanos
pescan calamares furtivamente al mar
chistina
y cangrejos también
libros
[Música]
a veces las intervenciones de los
guardacostas pueden tornarse violentas
el pasado 17 de septiembre una de ellas
salió mal
según la versión oficial los pescadores
furtivos atacaron a los guardacostas
quienes respondieron con armas de fuego
el resultado cuatro oficiales heridos y
un norcoreano muerto
después de largas negociaciones con el
fsb obtuvimos permiso para embarcarnos
con los guardacostas con el fin de
grabar los barcos incautados
bajo su vigilancia siete barcos
metálicos norcoreanos están estacionados
en la ensenada de najodka a 200 km de
vladivostok
el rector agustín
nuestra comunicación con los
guardacostas era mínima no se les
permite hablar con nosotros y tenemos
que ocultar sus rostros pero nos intriga
la presencia de tripulaciones
norcoreanas en esos barcos
tratamos de entrevistar al supervisor
encargado de escoltar los
cuánto tiempo llevan estacionados aquí
depende
son todos los que fueron arrestados este
verano sí y qué esperan
que se acabe la investigación como se
les dan provisiones
el consulado general de corea del norte
les da provisiones la comida el agua el
combustible todo eso es obligación del
consulado
entonces si el consulado no les está
provisiones nadie lo hace
el cónsul viene a visitarnos le
corresponde a él organizarlo todo no sé
cómo se hace realmente pero así es como
debe ser
al observar la vida en estos barcos
varios detalles llaman nuestra atención
la presencia de mujeres
[Risas]
y el hecho de que sus ocupantes usen
agua de mar para bañarse
queremos saber más sobre las condiciones
de su detención acompañados por un
traductor
decidimos acercarnos a ellos
[Música]
y de ocio
entonces ahora vídeo
[Música]
andar yo
enseguida me paseo
[Música]
jones hagan es ocho son millones a
grandeza boxeo
lugar
pero estos hombres especialmente el que
parece ser el capitán desconfían de
nosotros
[Música]
no nos dijeron nada más
por la pesca furtiva organizada en la
zona económica rusa se enfrentan a una
pena de hasta cinco años de prisión
en la mayoría de los casos serán
deportados
en el tribunal de najodka comienza un
caso más serio
buenos días pueden sentarse este hombre
es uno de los 161 pescadores furtivos
arrestados del 17 de septiembre al igual
que otros 17 se le acusa de intento de
homicidio contra los guardacostas el
jefe del grupo de investigación me pidió
que llevara a cabo una audiencia a
puerta cerrada porque una audiencia
pública podría resultar en la revelación
del secreto de la investigación nuestra
presencia fue lo que impulsó al
investigador jefe a solicitar una
audiencia a puerta cerrada y se les pide
salir de la sala a todos los que no
participan en la audiencia durante los
dos primeros días cuando sus detenciones
provisionales serán examinadas todas las
audiencias de los pescadores furtivos
norcoreanos permanecerán cerradas para
nosotros la audiencia se lleva a cabo a
puerta cerrada
sus botas de caucho y su ropa sucia le
dan la impresión de que no se han
cambiado desde su arresto hace diez días
algunos de ellos cojea
un hombre incluso tiene la pierna
enyesada
sin embargo el número oficial de muertos
es de 1 y 0 heridos entre los pescadores
furtivos norcoreanos nuestro traductor
trata de interrogarlos
crónica
basta
alguien h
o sea tienen miedo de contestarnos según
nuestras fuentes las fuerzas especiales
le dispararon en las piernas en
respuesta a su ataque la mayoría de los
abogados de oficio con los que nos
encontramos en el tribunal
parecen no preocuparse por su condición
porque tiene muletas que le pasó
no se lo pregunten no es mi trabajo como
abogada saber por qué tienen a dietas
stefan click es uno de los pocos
abogados que aceptó responderlos
en el pasado ha defendido a pescadores
cultivos de corea del norte
lo único que su cliente le habría dicho
es que le gustaría volver a casa en
corea del norte quería la casa de mi
padre kim jong-un quiere a la casa a mi
padre están asustados o no entienden lo
que pasó todos bien volver a casa aunque
me parece un crimen así se castiga con
la muerte hallazgo pocas en rusia se
enfrentan a la cadena perpetua se les
ordenó defender su barco y su botín a
toda costa por esta pesca ilegal a veces
pagan un precio aún más alto
[Música]
aquí está enterrado un ciudadano
extranjero norcoreano no identificado
y lo sacaron del agua en agosto de 2019
vladimir gorojovsky dirige una de las
dos funerarias de olga aquí en el
cementerio de la ciudad ya ha enterrado
anónimamente dos cuerpos de pescadores
norcoreanos arrastrados por el mar
él es el número uno luego habrá un
número dos luego un número tres y así
sucesivamente aparecen a lo largo de
nuestras costas dondequiera que la
corriente los lleve
a veces encontramos huesos o restos de
cadáveres
no se toman muestras de adn antes del
entierro no será posible conocer su
identidad algún día vladimir se hizo
cargo de los costos del funeral
intenté contactar a las autoridades
competentes lo logré y les pedí que me
ayudaran a contactar al consulado de
corea del norte
a la embajada o las organizaciones de
amistad ruso coreanas me dijeron
claramente porque los recoges déjelos
dónde están
[Música]
cuántos de esos pescadores furtivos han
muerto a lo largo de las costas rusas
rusia no da ningún balance en lo que
respecta a rusia y corea del norte tales
muertes no existen
el año pasado al otro lado de la isla
había un cadáver les tomó casi una
semana llevárselo y en el barco que se
corrimos los norcoreanos nos hicieron
entender que había seis o siete de ellos
al principio y sólo cuatro de ellos
sobrevivieron
en 2018 guau nadie vorobiof salvo a
cuatro pescadores norcoreanos de un
barco a la deriva en medio de una
tormenta
buena villa y su esposa los habían
acogido en su casa estas imágenes fueron
grabadas por un periodista de la
televisión local los habitantes del
pueblo apá se habían movilizado para
ayudarlos
nos alojamos aquí chile
en esta habitación había otra cama más
aquí y habíamos alojado a los cuatro y
dos de ellos estaban muy mal físicamente
los trajimos en un tractor desde la
playa y los trajimos hasta esta
habitación cuadros de inscripto como
todo para natalia la esposa de buena
villa en primer lugar había que darle
los primeros auxilios en cuanto al resto
no sabe mucho más
les preguntamos cómo llegaron allá nos
dijeron que eran pescadores que habían
quedado atrapados en un tifón que
entendían muy bien el ruso pero creo que
no tenían permitido hablar con nosotros
al día siguiente los guardacostas
llegaron y se los llevaron a
porque estos hombres arriesgan sus vidas
para ir a pescar fuera de sus fronteras
[Música]
para averiguarlo vamos al otro lado de
la península de corea en china
en la ciudad fronteriza de dandong
[Música]
situada en la desembocadura de un río de
menos de un kilómetro de ancho que
separa china de corea del norte
[Música]
remontando el curso del río la ciudad
norcoreana de sinuiju da paso a paisajes
rurales
allí la vida aparece congelada en otro
tiempo
[Música]
su principal medio de transporte de la
bicicleta hay muy pocos autos las motos
están reservadas para los oficiales del
ejército porque la gasolina no es un
producto para la gente común es un
producto controlado por el ejército la
gente común incluso la gente rica no
puede comprar gasolina lo que amanece
cicletada son gente como relativamente
rica
nuestro guía chino conoce bien el modo
de vida de los misteriosos vecinos de
enfrente su familia ha vivido en la
frontera durante varias generaciones la
gente que se ve en esa orilla son
pescadores norcoreanos son parte de una
unidad de producción los militares que
están en la orilla están ahí para
vigilarlos cuando los norcoreanos pescan
siempre son supervisados por los
soldados para evitar que huyan
nos están insultando
tenemos que irnos pero vámonos vámonos
una vez lejos de allí el guía nos dará
más explicaciones
esa gente es del ejército esté bien
grabando recogen piedras para lanzarte
los pecadores le dan todo su pescado a
la unidad de producción que a su vez se
lo da al ejército la unidad anota la
proporción de trabajo de los pescadores
tienen que darle todo el ejército
el ejército vende ese pescado o es para
consumo es para su consumo propio la
próspera política del ejército quiere
que el ejército esté bien alimentado la
unidad de producción funciona según el
modelo comunista la distribución de los
productos se raciona según el trabajo
cada persona recibe una ración de 150
gramos por comida se imagina lo que son
150 gramos de arroz
el ejército obtiene grandes ganancias
porque todo el pueblo le sirve al
ejército eso es lo que llaman su
prospera política de ejército
el ejército de kim jong-un dirige la
industria pesquera en corea del norte en
dandong otras fuentes nos confirmarán
esta información aquí los agentes los
hombres de negocios y las mercancías
pasan a diario por una carretera y un
puente ferroviario que une las costas de
china y corea del norte a pesar del
conjunto de sanciones adoptadas en 2017
por el consejo de seguridad de las
naciones unidas que prohíben entre otras
cosas la importación de mariscos de
corea del norte el negocio entre china y
corea del norte está prosperando y es en
dandong donde encontramos una de las
respuestas a nuestra investigación
logramos ponernos en contacto con un
agente que venden licencias de pesca a
barcos chinos en nombre del gobierno de
corea del norte
nuestro traductor cuya identidad
ocultamos por razones de seguridad
pretende estar interesado en una de
estas licencias
como garantía de la fianza el agente
incluso le envía fotos de una mujer que
dice ser su tía norcoreana junto con el
líder norcoreano kim jong un
se reunirá con nuestro traductor en su
habitación de hotel
buenos días
este es el señor y esta es mi novia
grabamos su reunión en cámara escondida
cada año unos 1000 bancos chinos van a
pescar a corea del norte corea del norte
otorga entre 800 y 1000 licencias al año
se les distribuyen al ejército al
partido y a los órganos de poder y como
no tienen dinero ganan dinero vendiendo
las no hay economía privada en corea del
norte así que para vender estas
licencias necesitan representantes en
chino el responsable de toda la zona de
corea del norte en el mar del japón fue
a ver a mi tía en persona y le dio
instrucciones para que vendiera todas
las licencias de esa zona y qué relación
tiene tu tía con corea del norte es
norcoreana y vive acá por ejemplo cuando
kim jong-un viaja al extranjero los
norcoreanos lo reciben en cada país
mi tía es la jefa del comité nacional de
bienvenida de china
el agente le explicará el procedimiento
firmas un contrato en china con mi tía
este contrato no es realmente público
porque no es del todo legal la licencia
que te mostré es una licencia temporal
luego cuando llegues a corea del norte
la cambias por una licencia oficial el
ejército norcoreano tiene un barco que
te lleva en 2016 el propio sub
comandante de la marina de corea del
norte comando el buque insignia
finalmente el agente sugirió que nuestro
traductor fuera a conocer a la famosa
tierra su oficina está en el último piso
del edificio de al lado en el antiguo
edificio del consulado de corea del
norte el gente quiere mostrar la vista
de corea del norte
esta vista es absolutamente hermosa
en la pared están las fotos de su tía
con kim jong-un
y aquí está la vía en persona
estoy resfriada no me siento bien
en tren este es el señor buenos días con
ella la conversación será principalmente
sobre el aspecto financiero la temporada
de pesca en el mar de japón comienza en
junio tienes que pagar por un año te
diremos cuánto es en total cada año
corea del norte establece una tarifa
diferente para su impuesto sobre los
recursos pesqueros este año
cambia todos los años dependiendo de la
zona son alrededor de 300.000 yuanes
unos 43 mil dólares y puedes pagar extra
por el acceso a ciertas áreas vas a
ganar mucho dinero tienen muchos
recursos hay una zona especial en la
frontera con rusia nadie va a pescar
allá todo lo que tienes que hacer es
pescar allá y serás rico
al vender sus recursos pesqueros a china
corea del norte asegura un ingreso de
divisas que es vital para su economía y
el que se ha visto privada desde las
sanciones
hasta su adopción en agosto de 2017
exportaba cada año mariscos a china por
valor de casi 200 millones de dólares
ahora estas exportaciones están
prohibidas
[Música]
pero en el gran mercado de döng bank al
sur de dandong los mariscos de corea del
norte siguen estando presentes
[Música]
de corea del norte tenemos almejas
berberechos pero principalmente tenemos
calamares muchos calamares
estos son triángulos de almejas
norcoreanas esto es carne de navaja
navajas rellenas de fideos e irás
rellenas de fideos todos estos productos
provienen del mar del este nosotros
mismos fuimos a pescar los en el barco
para venderlos aquí
en la jerga local el mar del este es el
mar de corea del norte pero cuando se le
pregunta sobre su licencia este
empresario no es muy claro
cuánto cuesta una licencia
cuanto cuesta no sé es una cooperación
de hace mucho tiempo necesito tus
productos y tú necesitas los míos
[Música]
algunos compran directamente en el mar
los productos vendidos por corea del
norte que los pescadores necesitados se
ven reducidos a pescar furtivamente
y otros compran licencias mensuales para
ir a pescar a las vecinas aguas
norcoreanas del mar amarillo o anuales
para ir a la zona de corea del norte en
el mar de japón al otro lado de la
península
una gran parte de estas licencias se
venden aquí en la provincia portuaria de
shandong el centro de la producción de
mariscos en china debido a la sobrepesca
los peces grandes de su golf o
desaparecieron gradualmente porque son
apreciados en el mercado tenemos pargo
castañuelas anchoas de granada carpas
negras terapias
estando
cada mes este empresario importa cerca
de 260 toneladas de pescado de corea del
sur en shandong el 75% de producción
proviene de la acuicultura el resto de
las importaciones y sobre todo de la
pesca en el extranjero antes había
suficientes peces ahora cada vez hay
menos no se puede pescar sin parar y
seguir teniendo tantos peces nuestros
barcos chinos equipados para procesar el
pescado van a corea del norte para
capturar calamares en grandes cantidades
hay un buen mercado para el calamar
y mira qué alto es el precio el chino no
podemos atrapar calamares
tenemos que ir a corea del norte
le pedimos a li qiang que nos llevara al
puerto más cercano para mostrarnos estos
barcos de pesca de altura algunos de
ellos se parecen extrañamente a los
arrastreros norcoreanos que vimos en
rúsia
este tipo de barco con su sistema de luz
apuesta especialmente hecho para la
pesca de calamares y como tiene grandes
gastos si no das suficiente rendimiento
registra un déficit a lo largo del año
en china hay pocos recursos es por eso
que todos van allá
en 2007 li qiang también quiso adquirir
una licencia para pescar en corea del
norte y en ese momento la administración
local de pesca incluso realizaba rifas
me llamaron por teléfono y me dijeron
que viniera a una reunión al final
dijeron ahora mismo es temporada de vida
en china tenemos 10 licencias quién las
quiere vayan a inscribirse hoy es
diferente hay muchos barcos y también
muchas licencias el procedimiento para
obtenerlas se ha simplificado las
relaciones diplomáticas entre china y
corea del norte ha mejorado quieres una
existencia adelante no hay problema solo
tienes que tener conexiones
[Música]
a pesar de esto li qiang ya no planea ir
a pescar a corea del norte demasiado
peligroso demasiado arriesgado
la licencia de por sí ya es muy caro y
además hay que pagar las comisiones
dependiendo de tu pesca por una tonelada
de ganas 10.000 yuanes y tienes que
darle 2000 también tienen que estar
regla si pescas en corea del norte
tienes que contratar norcoreanos en tu
barco y tienes que pagarle un salario
mensual pero no les das el dinero solo
tienes que dárselo a las autoridades
norcoreanas a la embajada al consulado a
esa gente incluso si vas con una
licencia no te paga mucho especialmente
este año los capitanes que volvieron
dijeron que no había estado bien
pescaron muy poco
[Música]
para preservar sus recursos pesqueros y
seguir vendiéndose los a china
corea del norte por su parte va a pescar
cada vez más lejos
estas imágenes nos fueron transmitidas
por los guardacostas japoneses
el año pasado rechazaron más de 1500
embarcaciones de corea del norte
[Música]
del lado ruso en virtud de un acuerdo de
1987 rusia le asignaba cuotas de pesca a
corea del norte todos los años hasta
luego estas fueron suspendidas
debido a la sobrepesca esta zona del
pacífico la más prolífica del mundo se
está quedando sin peces y los esquemas
secretos de pesca furtiva escapan a
todas las estadísticas ecológicas y
humanitarias
[Música]
e
gracias por acompañarnos en esta emisión
de reporteros el documental recuerda que
puede ingresar a nuestra página web más
24 punto com para ver esta emisión y las
anteriores hasta la próxima semana
[Música]